[Music]
a century ago this sound was new to the
people of Britain brought here by an
all-black group called The Southern
syncopated Orchestra
founded in the US it would eventually
recruit musicians from Africa and the
Caribbean and just after the first world
war they embarked on a tour of Britain
of one of the 35 musicians is my
grandfather
Frank Bates from Barbados very proud of
what he accomplished because I would
just assume that travel was so difficult
back then how they found their way
around Europe and originally when they
were coming from New York it was for a
three-year tour that to me is impressive
The Bravery of them and then the
assumption that they're going to be so
well received and well received they
were multiple standing ovations at each
performance
they made a huge impression across
Europe and even managed to convince
critics of the day that the musical art
of the Negro should be welcomed
encouraged and cultivated language we
would now consider offensive but
intended as a compliment just being out
on the street would have been there
would have been objects of curiosity but
the reality is it was their music that
moved people and they moved people so
much and after the concert here they
were invited to give a concert at
Buckingham Palace but on the 9th of
October in 1921 at the height of their
Fame tragedy struck they were traveling
to their next venue in Dublin when their
ship was hit by two separate vessels 36
people died including nine of the
musicians and the remaining members
completed the tour in Ireland but soon
the SSO would disband and as far as we
know their music was never recorded but
it did exist we know about it we can use
our imaginations to reform and to be
inspired by that story
and this is what it could have sounded
like as imagined by Julian Joseph and
Patrick
there were abilities Way Beyond the
expectations of what
um black people were thought to be able
to do this was spreading the the gospel
of what intellectual Black Entertainment
was
[Music]
schmann Freeman Powell Sky News
[Music]